Jordan clay divincenzo kaminga and
Looney three of the warrior starters not
playing tonight
boban and Kaminsky back in back in the
day
and he Thompson catch and shoot three
Nate Thompson's got Kaminsky on them
a work out of here we shot clock at five
[Music]
with a step back threes
hey Thompson
four team fouls I was getting excited
because the Warriors have shot 11 free
throws I feel happy all right Thompson
catching two three
Jabari Smith Jr trying to shoot the gaps
Clay Thompson credit Jabari Smith he was
right in his airspace but I made it
anyway how good is Klay Thompson
vicenzo can three Defenders with him
hey Tom's a nice handout and dropped in
the three kamenga creating that you're
on the back end of a back to back you
want to win this game but you don't
wanna you're heavy mini guys
26 tonight driving by Jabari I got the
quickness on him I'm gonna draw one more
Defender
garuba doesn't know where to go he's
just focused on Patrick Baldwin Jr and
Looney with divincenzo clay and Ty
Jerome okay
[Applause]
Clayton had it strips
how did he make that play
that is such a tough shot to make but it
does not matter look at drifting it's
like you're shooting at him they're
putting garuba the defender on clay and
Clay saying Go away I'll create
something myself his three
he's got ten again
there's been a different energy to his
game tonight
but you also want to make sure you
secure win number 30 because every night
in the west matters how do you use clay
here clay catching shoot three there's
11. he's coming from scoring he's just
got so much bounce though Minnesota on
Sunday what time's that game 4 30 4 30.
not be late Sunday play three that's